normalement au mois d'octobre la saison
campaign tire à sa fin mais pas ici
peter après les leurs trois enfants de 9
à 11 et 17 ans vivent dans cette
roulotte de 8 mètres de long depuis
trois mois de leurs lits ils installent
un autre de sotuba romeria puis il
partage la salle de bain avec monsieur
richard le mode de vie original qui pour
les peter nos pas choisi parce que les
logements disponibles et surtout
abordable sont devenus des denrées rares
très rares à charlottetown le taux
d'inoccupation est presque nul il est à
0,2 pour cent un taux inférieur à celui
des grandes villes canadiennes
winters et paul et peter peuvent payer
jusqu'à 1500 dollars de loyer par mois
les malgré cela le recherche quotidienne
sauvé le tribunal non
les locations court terme comme airbnb
la hausse du nombre d'immigrants et des
étudiants internationaux sont les
principaux facteurs qui font pression
sur le marché immobilier
l'an dernier sur les 4300 étudiants à
temps plein plus de 25 % venaient de
notre pays
l'université a dû prendre des mesures
extraordinaires
les hôtels sont devenus des maisons et
des maisons sont devenues des hôtels
c'est le monde à l'envers croit ce
défenseur de l'accès au logement qui
réclame dans cette campagne électorale
que les parties reconnaissent qu'il ya
péril en la demeure
ni de parole la petite ville de 38000
résidant à des problèmes des grandes
villes il ya beaucoup de services à
charles attend le maire de la capitale
philippe brun en fait son cheval de
bataille
je sais que les partitions provincial et
fédéral sont fâchés avec moi mais c'est
pas mon problème est un problème à
charlatans la province a reçu jusqu'à
présent 50 millions de dollars de la
stratégie nationale sur le logement des
libéraux de justin trudeau
il faut travailler plus fort à lui seul
ce projet de 50 logements abordables à
charlottetown en coût de 14 millions et
aura pris plus d'un an à voir le jour
trop peu trop tard alors que l'on estime
à plus de 1000 personnes ou familles
comme celle d'april et peter sur des
listes d'attentes pour trouver du
logement christine boutin
l approche de l'hiver la mère de famille
est inquiète cours et le moral de tous
et tape la part du fonds
ces listes
et les enfants se sont confinés april
n'a pas l'impression que les politiciens
comprennent l'urgence for which they
michael accord ce mardi à paris pour la
convaincre d'aller voter le 21 octobre
ici elisa série radio-canada charlotin